how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things
marvel cinematic universe and in the
midst of all of this great
and exciting news that we're getting
about the mcu with spider-man 3 the one
division trailer dropping the falcon and
the winter soldier starting the film
again
as well as other projects resuming
production that still has not stopped
marvel from pushing back movies and not
specifically marvel but
disney in its entirety and warner
brothers and dc
slate has moved back almost an entire
year as well and of course this is
making a lot of people upset
a lot of people want the release of
these awesome new projects that both
studios have coming up
and when it comes to black widow
specifically a lot of fans
are saying that they should just release
black widow on disney plus premier
access like they did
mulan and as it turns out there are some
people at
disney saying that they think black
widow should go
to vaude video on demand on disney plus
premiere
access dan loeb the hedge fund manager
for third point and one of disney's
top investors has urged disney to
bypass black widow's theatrical release
and go straight to streaming on disney
premier access
now here's some very important
information that you need to know
this week disney announced a
restructuring that would immediately
shift its primary focus to streaming via
disney plus
espn plus and hulu platforms and with
this news disney decided to send pixar's
soul straight to streaming now coming
out on disney plus
on christmas day and this is without
mulan's 29.99 premiere access fee
this is going to simply be put on disney
plus for free
so disney just had a restructuring that
is going to focus more on
streaming it's going to focus more on
disney plus
now this is big because it definitely
affects black widow that combined with
one of disney's top investors
urging disney to bypass the theater
release and put black widow on disney
plus
these are two really big things that
just happened that could get disney and
marvel studios to switch black widow
from its theatrical release
to a release on disney plus those two
combined with the fact that theaters are
now shutting down
that and analysts say that the theaters
that are now open may shut down again
and it may be at least
two years before we see a normal return
to theaters
these are all things that are going to
shift black widow from the theaters to
disney plus
dan leweb talked about black widow going
to disney plus in an interview with
variety where he said
my understanding is that the old line
executives don't want to go
over the top with their big tentpole
movies which is why they announced they
were pushing black widow and other
movies to 2021.
i don't think they appreciate the tiger
they have by the tail which is to say
the value they can drive by moving into
a subscription model
which has been adopted by everyone from
microsoft to amazon
it's so value accretive he went on to
say what netflix has
is this immense subscriber base that
allows it to invest in an enormous
amount of content and amortize that to
get more subscribers
disney isn't there yet but they need to
get there as quickly as possible
if they don't get critical mass in their
subscriber base they will be permanently
disadvantaged
versus netflix so this is big for black
widow
disney just shifted their main focus to
streaming one of disney's
top investors is saying that black widow
needs to go on disney plus and
unfortunately many theater chains
are shutting down and if things continue
this way it looks like black widow is
going to be releasing on disney plus
so be sure to subscribe so you stay up
to date on everything that is happening
with black widow and let me know down
below would you like to see black widow
in theaters even if it comes out
two years from now or would you like to
see it on disney plus if that means
getting it sooner
of course we all think that black widow
deserves a theatrical release which she
does but if we have to wait over a year
for it would you rather wait
or have it come out on disney plus let
me know in the comments down below and
don't forget to subscribe so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win an iron spider funko pop
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me